all right switch over to the irish slang
i want to try a couple of these bad boys
right
all right we're going to read some irish
phrases and and guess what they mean
in in honor of matt the
most nothing love island character of
all time
wet the tea
sit down there sit down there and relax
oh sit down there and relax while i go
wet the tea i mean i would assume that's
making some tea
wet the tea i would maybe say that's
like foreplay
like come on what make the t wet oh wait
is it are those the answers
no it's basically like a sentence but it
basically just means go to get like your
favorite drink i didn't know you guys
wanted to guess them so i just i just
thought you wanted to show off your
fancy irish accent
yeah yeah deal
okay
acting the maggot stop acting the maggot
you naughty hobgoblins
[ __ ] is that
[Music]
like you're being like a little devious
little pest
you're being annoying okay that's how we
say that in america stop being a devious
little pest dude
tyler quit being a devious little pest
and do your homework
[Music]
that dose is going round oh yeah that's
like uh yeah it's like you got coveted
basically yeah
brad's got the flu god help him that
dose is going around i heard he got it
from the pfizer vaccine
he shouldn't have taken it i told him
that he should just stay away from those
pokes
that's the full sentence yeah nice
had doses going around that dose is that
what they say about coven
i lost me tasting me smell that dust is
going round probably is is that what it
means kyle yeah you know
okay okay what's next
why you love a time oh that's like we
[ __ ] it was lit
yeah whale of a time
it was a whale of a time
sounds like a green day album it was a
it does it was a walleye of a time
that's when you see wale play at a club
and [ __ ] where are we yeah we've done
that
penn state penn state went out to like
the
like maine student club there and wale
played for uh for exactly 11 minutes
it was
it was horrible
i mean
he was there to get his 40k and dip yeah
i mean he did what he had to do he
definitely did what he had that was
definitely in the contract you have to
play for 11 minutes on the nose and he
didn't play for a single minute longer
than nah he was out of there yeah
goodbye
uh sucking diesel oh yeah
that's when you're
that stuck oh now you're sucking decent
like
i can't even do an iris accident that's
when two bros suck each other off
not your sucking diesel my filthy boyo
[Music]
the jacks
tell you what
you get another round while i head to
the jacks it's got to be to take a piss
oh like you have a pisser
across the smaller pond yes yeah yeah
drinking word these are words for
drinking lash
let's go on the lash this sunday okay on
the tear
we were on the tear ossified we got
ossified off two pints of gat that
sounds like a nerd word i don't believe
that
i don't know i don't believe irish
people would say a nerdy ass word like
that falsified
we got ossified this weekend
it kind of sounds like annihilated or
something like that yeah yeah yeah like
it sounds kind of like an action word
but the
yeah
okay maybe the yeah all right i'll take
it back is that it all right well thanks
for joining us for the irish slang oh
you're sucking diesel no
no
no you're sucking diesel now my filthy
boy say that to your bro next time you
guys are drinking
you're sucking diesel now man my filthy
boy oh who the [ __ ] is what diesel would
you just call me dog dude you're my
filthy boy
don't call me filthy dude that's weird
this is a filthy boil right here
calling someone filthy is a horny ass
word
you filthy little deviant filthy little
deviant
you filthy little devious pest
dad why are your pants down
because you're my filthy little boy
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] on unseen bits uh i think we
have the full clip of this it's
i don't even know it's liam bowing to
jake what is the card i don't know i
don't watch unseen bits because it sucks
but this is apparently is
what happened on it
uh i'll talk over the copyright
looking to her eyes looking to her eyes
he's killed it you filthy little boy oh
look into her you look into her eyes
when you see it
right into her eyes
what
[Laughter]
so yeah so
what else got messed up is fey and teddy
well now we got these two new folks yeah
apparently priya is like a tory
i guess she said like her man crush
mondays like boris johnson what yeah
yeah
what yeah i don't know man
why i don't know
i was just like bro she looks like
[ __ ]
anne hathaway out of like a monster
munch bag like she's like
it's like the same sort of like
i don't know
similar vibe yeah
that's why right yeah boris right there
filthy boy yeah it's a filthy boil for
sure
[Music]
yeah is it something like where she's
like i'm in love with his policies so
he's like my it's like you know my man
crush monday's biting because
you know he's co i don't know the way
he's dealing with covid or she really
she wants to [ __ ] him i don't know
i mean yeah it's probably like a i think
that'd be the equivalent of like a like
a mega mom or something yeah um
but yeah she seems so out of place on
that show
yeah yeah way too proper i don't like i
don't like when they bring in people
like that hugo is kind of the same way
where it's like they think they're
smarter than everyone else yeah the
first thing she says i'm a med student
she was like guess what i do because i
want to hear you you know when they're
like talking about careers and she's
like what do you do i mean whatever what
do you do she's like guess
it's like i want to hear what stupid
[ __ ] you think i do so that i can tell
surprise you by my real job that's
actually impressive
just like whatever that's just like i
don't know
yeah not to say you shouldn't like
brag about being a med student but don't
go on a reality show with the show
people yeah
it's like no i'm hot and i have a good
job so
she's like she's like i'm in my fifth
year i'm almost done
someone comes out on like the [ __ ]
you know the sun or some [ __ ] they're
like
uh yeah she's just like a nursing
student she sucks at school and yeah
uh she's just been retaking the same
here yeah she's finally gonna graduate
yeah julian only she's a doctor i know
this girl yeah
but yeah she's apparently um
i don't know i could be wrong about that
we're probably going to get like a lot
of english comments they're like the
[ __ ] tory
you're [ __ ] dude what is it what is
that this is like ultra conservative
and that's what
boris johnson is yeah he was you know
brexit and all that ah gotcha
sorry i'm stupid when it comes to this
stuff well so yeah
apparently she said like her man crush
monday is this dude i see and some
people people are like giving her heat
for it
i think it's more like
people are laughing you know i guess
people were like
calling for more diversity on the show
and then they just bring this robot
person in
she seems like a robot that's my biggest
take from yeah
a med student
i am a med student yeah
i'm here for teddy
teddy teddy matt i am that's how you
know cause
so you know she's a robot programmed
because
no one would like matt unless they're
appropriate
shut the [ __ ] up dude
i'm sorry he has one stat if you're
watching he has one stat that just
trumps it all what you can be six seven
and boring yep
you can be six seven and say no is he
that tall he's yeah he's like six really
tall yeah look at [ __ ] liam that guy
just says nothing but like
[ __ ] and [ __ ] yeah
i'm absolutely
crazy oh my god he's got the chad he's
so funny let me see your bottom lips oh
real
real let me see you're on the lips
yeah as long as you're tall it doesn't
matter anymore it doesn't matter
evidence of that dude
and the oh she all she also runs ultra
marathons too yeah what kind of [ __ ] is
that i was kind of like
do you [ __ ] idiot
really
you're turning up the volume yeah she's
talking about her marathon
hold on hold on
i just stop talking let me hear
now i have to rewind it i don't know
the details of her last run i run ultra
marathons yeah
so obviously you do you run on solar
power